welcome back 303 in the cut is gourmet
food on the go and i'm here with one of
the owners giuliana how are you doing
buddy good how are you today thank you
for bringing your truck down here first
off before we get into the food what's
the back story on 303 in the cut the
back story on the name so 303 is where
we get our green chile from i grew up
here but i was born in colorado uh in
the code this refers to being hard to
find working out a car
food trucks are you working out of the
car you know and you just won a big
award tell everyone what you guys just
wanted this is this is huge i did so uh
we were just voted uh best food truck at
great american foodie fest which is one
of the largest foodies fest in the
country um for best food shops you're
competing against easily 100 food trucks
that is a big accomplishment now let's
talk about what some of the food that
you guys offer what do you guys have uh
so we do american classics with a green
chili twist um here
whoa
i think um this is our smothered green
chili fries right we smoke our chicken
house make our pinto beans everything
made from scratch this is a green chili
burrito all right so
wow
look at that
that looks like it feeds like two or
three people that serving size yeah well
i try to we want food to be affordable
but still with great quality um so you
know we have a late night spot in
chinatown it's like brick and mortar
same spot same times every week so it's
kind of what we're building up someone's
watching right now and there's great
buzz about you guys right now and they
see that you won the award they're
seeing their food is that the best way
to find you is on thursday nights what
they want to book you for like a private
event yeah so whether it's google my
website instagram facebook twitter i'm
on all the platforms 303 in the cut you
know you just reach out to me about
catering or otherwise you can find us at
our normal late night challenge town
location is this we're inside your truck
this is a really cool thing to be inside
your truck yeah is this where you do all
the work is there any pre-prep in
advance or everything is done inside you
know there is a prep done at the
commissary that we have and whatnot but
as far as here we really focus on
everything being made to order you know
things not coming out of the freezer
things not being prepped that we buy
just throw in uh you know we take great
care of what we do
where do you get your inspiration for
making something like this where do you
get your inspiration uh so you know in
colorado they do some other green chili
fries kind of like carne asada fries um
he's just a little more flavor a little
heat to it
as far as the burrito if the burrito
doesn't have grill marks you know it's
not a burrito you know so is this what i
should try right here yeah so i got the
burrito got that this is our seasoned
fries we make all our sauces in-house
ranch throughout
the garden i mean look at that right
there hello how good do i look oh my
gosh all right let me take a bite here
wow
that is a um a parade of flavors
inside your mouth i've been very lucky
you know uh been guided and mentored by
uh cuckoo burger the owners
yeah they've been helping me with stuff
and zeroing stuff so i've been very
fortunate in that so i'm trying to raise
the food game in las vegas and you
certainly have this is delicious thank
you so much for joining us 303 in the
cup find them on instagram i'm gonna eat
and rocky i'm gonna send it over to you